hey youtubers is charlie thank you
everyone that submitted questions from
my walking deck you nee tons of WTF des
to talk about so let's just get to it
careful for spoilers in case you haven't
seen the episode yet I noticed a lot of
people in the comments blaming Noah for
Beth and tyreese's death I suppose you
could make that Association but I think
the group would have gone to the
hospital no matter what like Daryl had
found the car tracked them back to the
hospital no gave them a little extra
context someone probably still would
have died in that attack that's what
Rick's initial plan was he was gonna
storm the hospital like a full-on
assault that's what last seen with the
people at the hospital was all about it
was trying to position dawn against rick
is like a you know who's crazier who's
right who's wrong situation if you take
it at its most literal andrew lincoln is
the main protagonist of the show it's
told from Rick's perspective largely
even though it's an ensemble so
technically he's the hero other people
or the villain but just like breaking
bad shows us the hero can also become
the villain at times ultimately when the
show is dead and gone and we get a full
look at Rick's development you know from
Season one to the final season I don't
think he's gonna go down as a villain
there's always gonna be something to
bring him back to humanity typically
that's Carl and Judith I think the
double meaning there is that they're the
reason that i am still saying like i
haven't gotten completely nutbar that's
also something really interesting to
debate you know like has Rick lost his
marbles or not dude because he looks
like he has his together doesn't
mean he has his together and in the
case of tyreese's death that was a
little bit of carelessness all the
survivors probably have like low-grade
PTSD to a certain degree and Tyreese
hazard to have hallucinations so he
probably would have ended up in a
situation like that no matter where the
group went going to know his house just
kind of sped that up a little bit on two
questions though here we go oh well asks
do you think that Maggie will go to Rick
with what father Gabriel said to damage
control with Deanna or handle father
Gabriel herself that's an interesting
thought like her totally going after
Gabriel I think what's gonna happen is
is she's gonna pretend like she didn't
hear anything she won't go to Deanna
first she'll go to Rick and be like oh
my God look at what just happened and
then they'll try to do some damage
control we saw clips of Rick standing
with Deanna over the graves the people
that died during the warehouse mission
so she is going to learn about her son's
death
and she knows what Gabriel said so she
and wrinkle had that kind of standoffish
moment that will probably be damage
control at least from from Rick's
perspective as crazy as Maggie can get I
don't think that she's gonna go after
Gabriel herself that seems like
something Carol might do she's like the
cleaner of the group she cleans up
messes especially cookie size messes
next question DC FC fanatic asks the EDM
song internet friends is by a knife
party the part of the song says you're
all gonna die was an omen I actually
thought that was a little on the nose I
you know sometimes it's hard to tell the
way they play metaphors in the show
sometimes they're really obvious
sometimes they're more subtle I thought
it was funny or whenever Eugene use the
van so I thought it would have been more
appropriate if they if they had played
the lyrics whenever he was doing that it
was a nice opportunity for the people in
the back of the van to make that little
joke but I think when you look at it
from a bigger perspective it was just
stacking the deck against Aidan like
he's just doing all these things super
carelessly not not thinking things
through of course playing loud music it
was totally attract walkers you know if
he'd been thinking he wouldn't have shot
the walker with the grain out his chest
he would have noticed that and he
wouldn't be playing super loud EDM music
I really wish someone had video from
comic-con the highlight reel they played
of Andrew Lincoln gettin amped up before
this scene he was filming in season four
it showed his process like he literally
like walked around screaming like a
crazy man pounding on stuff to get
cranked up that feels like it would be
an appropriate place to put some knife
party next question miss latin girl asks
his father gabriel it goes didn't he
seemed crazy enough that maybe Deanna
will take his confession as a man losing
it it kind of seemed like she was just
trying to get a crazy person out of her
house yeah yeah she definitely had that
look in her eye like oh my god this guy
is totally nuts I think the writers are
just trying to build her character out
is someone who's a little more
calculating she's not gonna rush to
judgment because even if she believes
that Rick is a terrible person it does
terrible things if she feels like that's
an asset to the safe zone and she can
somehow control or contain him then she
might totally choose to get rid of
Gabriel because if rick is necessary and
Gabriel is only going to cause problems
she's going to want to get rid of the
problem next question Renan asks have
you ever thought of Rick's group as the
antagonist yeah I definitely I think
they want you to question that but it
depends on which perspective you're
taking whenever your watch
in episode if you think that the
Alexandria people are the protagonists
then yes Rick's group are the
antagonists from a larger perspective
the show follows two survivors so
technically they're the protagonists and
everyone else is the antagonist anyone
that comes up against them but within
scenes yes like the survivors can be
antagonists like I said it's a breaking
bad situation where sometimes you have a
main character that isn't always like
puppies and rainbows next question
though chaos Tobias asks why did Maggie
just charge up the stairs and getting
Gabriel's grill well I think she didn't
want to make things worse she also might
have just been frozen in terror like oh
my god what's happening because she
really only walked up like halfway
through his conversation it's nice to
see the survivors get smarter and
smarter like they learn from their
experiences don't just rush in guns
blazing I mean that's kind of what
Abraham did but Abraham's relatively new
to the group so I think over time he'll
learn from his mistakes and he'll be
less quick to rush in next question
Nathan asks is it just me that wishes
Morgan got a spinoff no I am sure there
are a ton of people that would love a
Morgan spin-off that we just we haven't
seen a lot of the characters so they'd
have to go to some really strange places
Morgan does have a really big storyline
in the comics but it kind of happens
away from the survivor so it'd be it'd
be very different type of show it kind
of makes me think of like the classic
Hulk series with Bill Bixby just like
walking down the side of the highway by
himself the incredible Morgan that'd be
that'd be good name for the spin-off
show the incredible Morgan next question
split sniper asks is it just me or does
Carole hate kids now no I don't think
that she hates kids I think I assume
you're talking about the scene where she
was trying to get Sam to go away I think
she just wanted to push him away to show
that she wouldn't have to hurt him like
sending him away as a way to protect him
from future harm because if he kept
pushing around and wouldn't go away
that'd be a liability to the group just
more opportunities to compromise the
plants that they were making so sending
him away could have been an act of
charity on her part isn't that what you
do when you really want someone to go
away you just be really mean to them her
ears really didn't prick up until he
rebuffed her until he was like that's
okay we don't have to be friends I can
just stand here quietly we don't have to
talk she's like wait a minute okay I'm
being terrible to you why do you want to
stay what is going on here next question
though Mille excess where do you think
the Alexandria people are getting gas
and fuel from for all to be
because they're using well you know the
community they have is supposed to be
self-sustainable so they they probably
have like some form or source of fuel
inside the community but they also do a
lot of ranging so they apply bring a lot
of supplies back we haven't seen in a
while but they're always gas stations
around so they ply send people out to
get barrels of gas to bring back we do
know that the electricity that they draw
is from a self sustainable source so
that's what the electricity comes from
next question button sack asks do you
think there's going to be a conflict of
interest between Rick wanting to kill
Pete and the group needing him to help
with Tara's recent condition definitely
I think I think he'll help with Tara and
then it'll just make it that much harder
for Rick to kill him I think they want
Rick to really stress over it like after
what Carol said he's like okay this guy
clearly has to die he's abusing children
but if his skills are so valuable to the
group and we haven't seen another doctor
that we know of killing him might cause
more problems than it would solve really
I think this is all just so that it's
not an easy quick decision like Rick
isn't just gonna walk over there and pop
them in the head next question Reese
asks do you think that Darrell will find
Morgan and bring him back and do you
think it will have another major
character death in the finale yeah I
mean I definitely think there'll be
another big character little died in the
finale probably someone from the
Alexandria safe zone if not someone from
inside the survivors right now the safe
zone people are like higher on my hit
list as for Morgan I feel like they need
to tease this other big group of
villains like these wolves supposedly
that are ranging around so even if Daryl
does find Morgan I also think he's gonna
find some clues about the Wolves just
because they're in and around the area
thank you so much everyone for so many
questions these are always a ton of fun
to do I think I think we all definitely
are an agreement that this last episode
was one of the better ones from the back
half of the season so far or just season
five in general so I'm really optimistic
the finale is gonna be just full of WTF
amazingness if there's any special bonus
videos that you guys want me to do is we
head into the finale just let me know
I'll post my episode 15 video next
Sunday after the episode airs so be sure
to subscribe to get that and
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner homemade boat that stitch is an
awesome channel name you win a
twenty-dollar amazon gift card just
message me on the on the back end of my
channel so I get your contact info let's
all say one last goodbye to Noah and
Aiden she's two of the most
amazing-looking death scenes you know
whether or not you like the fact that
they died but tonight
episode of the flash you can actually
click here to watch the latest trailer
breakdown just so amazing this grant
gustin lightsabers that's all I'll say
and you can click here for all my
Walking Dead videos thank you so much
for watching I'll see you guys tonight
let's all do the thing